[Música]
y él
mi nombre es jobs y yáñez y sí sí me
llamo hope si no es mi apodo ni mi
nombre artístico así ha sido poner mis
padres y apps y yáñez actualmente soy
blogger conferencista empresaria estando
pera y comediante y con comediante
espero que un día no se les ocurre decir
me oye tú quieres comediante pues
cuentan un chiste porque soy la persona
más salada del mundo realmente mi
comedia se basa en darle un giro de 180
grados a las cosas negativas a las cosas
tristes convirtiéndolas en positivas
aunque hace poco tiempo me di cuenta que
realmente lo que yo hacía era motivar y
se los voy a explicar a como lo siento
en este momento yo vengo de una familia
de muy bajos recursos sin embargo el
dinero nunca fue impedimento para que mi
familia sobre saliera o saliera adelante
y se los voy a decir con una sola
palabra que siempre me decía mi papá
extra ordinarios así es mi familia una
familia extraordinaria y no es que yo me
sienta la gran cosa ahí les va yo por
ejemplo soy el resultado de varios
intentos aunque los científicos le
llaman prueba y error o aproximaciones
sucesivas y si así es la vida cada vez
nos aproximamos más a nuestras metas
pero con el paso del tiempo entendido
que éstas no siempre se logran de la
noche a la mañana siempre hay algo más
hoy estoy parada en este escenario
intentando contarles quién soy
yo nací en una ciudad del noroeste de
méxico llamada culiacán sinaloa
mi padre leonardo yáñez el danzante de
venado un nombre muy reconocido a la
danza y mi mamá una mujer muy guapa rubí
madrid' ganadora del certamen de belleza
la musa del arte y yo jabs y yáñez con
una mínima carga genética de mis padres
si ahí les van mis papás decidieron
meterme a todo tipo de clase de
actividades halladas a flamenco a canto
actuación a ballet y la verdad es que yo
no sé cómo le hacían porque mis papás no
tenían dinero para eso cuando realmente
me di cuenta que estábamos muy mal era
cuando desayunábamos comíamos y cenamos
siempre lo mismo
yo me acuerdo que ese no era mi problema
desayunar comer y cenar lo mismo no era
mi problema está bien con tal de ir a
clases de ballet
el problema fue aprender a detectar las
clases sociales yo me acuerdo que
llegaba a clases de ballet y veía que
llegaban mis compañeritos en unos carros
bien bonitos con chófer muchacha y todo
es más se bajaba la niña bailando vale
no y eso no es todo la muchacha
también bailaba ballet y el chófer se
subía al carro
bailando ballet también pero mi mamá y
yo no nos quedamos atrás mi mamá y yo
llegamos en un carro bien largo bien
grandote de que habían 30 personas
sentadas 40 paradas el chofer muchacho y
todo el camión el camión urbano
estando en clases de ballet yo platicaba
con mis compañeras y les pregunté oye a
ver a qué se dedica tu papá y me dice mi
papá es empresario howard y se le
ocurrió preguntarme y tu papá que se
dedica mi papá
mi papá baila la danza del venado
inmediatamente pude ver sus rostros wow
como que baila la danza del venado y yo
si en ese momento entendí que mi papá
estaba haciendo algo extraordinario mi
papá era una persona extraordinaria me
sentía muy orgullosa
justo a la edad de 6 años decidí que
quería ser empresaria tanto que un día
llegó mi papá y le dije papá quiero ser
empresaria con una mesa ya fuera de la
casa con una cartulina que diga se
venden piedras interesantes y papá
cabrón como que piedras interesantes si
papá yo voy a juntar todas las piedras y
las voy a poner en esta mesa hija las
piedras no se venden no papá yo escuché
de los grandes empresarios de los papás
de mis amigas que siempre tu producto
tiene que tener un valor agregado que
pues ese es mi valor ponerle un
significado que creen se me vendieron
todas las piedras yo no sé si por
lástima pero se me vendieron todas
en la secundaria yo seguía con mi
espíritu emprendedor
y yo dije bueno pues mi abuela mi tía
hace pan pues yo también puedo vender
pan y decidí fundar mi segunda empresa
pan intur y empresa dedicada a la
repostería fina que en realidad vendía
pan bollitos empanadas por hijos pan
casero no pero yo siempre con la
mentalidad en alto entonces yo voy a
hacer una gran empresaria pues que creen
salí a venderlo todas las tardes y no se
me vendía el pan pero eso sí yo también
aprendí de los grandes empresarios que
la mercancía nunca se echaba a perder
pues me empecé a comer todo el pan
empecé a engordar y engordar y engordar
y mientras tanto seguían mis clases de
ballet en la prepa me di cuenta que no
podía pasar tanto tiempo sentada y yo le
dije a mi papá un día papá ya no quiero
estudiar que no de veras que si no estás
completa hija a ver yo no terminé la
prepa tú tienes que terminar la prepa
papá tú y yo no somos iguales yo no
quiero estudiar tengo hambre y aclaro no
hambre de comida no tengo hambre de
salir a comerme el mundo quiero ser
empresaria hija tienes que estudiar yo
no terminé la prepa te propongo que
estudies los sábados y entre semana
trabaje si yo papá esa idea es perfecta
como no se me había ocurrido y me dice
sí y terminamos la prepa juntos
no papá no puede ser efectivamente
terminamos la prepa juntos
orilla por mi pasión en los negocios y
mis ganas de ser empresaria decidí
estudiar administración de empresas los
sábados y entre semana la licenciatura
en ballet y contemporáneo y ahí en la
licenciatura de ballet y contemporáneo
comienza mi calvario ya que tanto
alumnos como maestros inician un
hostigamiento hacia mí hacia mi cuerpo
hasta mi persona porque bien sabemos que
las bailarinas tienen que ser delgadas
tienen que ser altas no tienen que tener
piernas nalgas y yo en ese entonces
pesaba aproximadamente unos 20 kilos más
recuerdo perfectamente que llegué a la
dirección la directora del salón y me
dice ya sí a la dirección llegue a la
dirección están todos mis maestros
reunidos
y me dicen jacques y aquí están tus
papeles no puedes continuar en esta
escuela porque estás demasiado gorda
yo sé que a lo mejor a algunos les da
risa pero en ese momento pude sentir un
dolor que no se imaginan como les
explica a mis maestros que mis papás
venían haciendo un esfuerzo constante
que a veces no tenían nada para
desayunar comer y cenar que mi papá
leonardo yáñez el danzante venado
reconocido en todo sinaloa y mama
hermosa guapa la musa del arte y yo
gorda es en serio me van a correr por
ser gorda yo quiero poner mi escuela
happ si no puedes continuar agarré mis
papeles llegue a la casa y le dije de
nuevo y papas papá mamá me corrieron de
la escuela y esta vez no falla en un
intento más de ser empresaria falla en
un intento más de ser exitosa y
extraordinaria me encerré en mi cuarto a
comer
y estaba hundida en depresión cuántos
días no se fueron quizás semanas
y ahora viene una etapa muy determinante
en mi vida que he contado tantas veces y
la quiero seguir contando porque no
quiero que se me olvide
ustedes saben que la depresión no tiene
cara verdad no tiene rostro o bueno al
menos eso dicen algunas personas pero yo
confieso que así es como surgieron mis
primeros vídeos en depresión
incluso en algunos de mis vídeos se
pueden ver rostros altamente
identificados como esquizofrénicos
paranoicos psicópatas y la verdad es que
yo navego con todas estas identidades
todos los días y si thatcher me de loca
pero la verdad es que no todo el mundo
se atreve a ventilar públicamente sus
taras emocionales debilidades y
flaquezas yo lo hago todos los días con
la intención de verme reflejada en la
sociedad pero también le digo a la gente
que soy bonita que soy exitosa que me
amo que soy amable y no todo el mundo se
atreve a hacerlo encerrada en mi
habitación decido grabar mi primer vídeo
el cual era solamente para mí se sube
por error a las redes sociales se hace
viral y comenzaron a surgir los fans
pero también los haters sale a la calle
la gente me reconocía y la verdad me
parecía absurdo
me saludaba gente que yo no conocía yo
decía se están burlando de mí o se están
riendo conmigo
decidí entrar en el mundo de las redes
sociales
y luego surgió mi cuarta empresa
guidance todo para la danza
mientras estaba en clases de ballet yo
decidí abrir una tienda sin antes contar
que mis alumnas pues también eran
alumnas de bajos recursos comencé a fiar
a regalar ya no saber cobrar quebré de
nuevo
estando las redes sociales también
empezaron a llegar ofertas de trabajo
pero también ofertas de fiestas y empecé
a salir a los antros les cuento que yo
ni siquiera tomaba pero ahí comencé a
tomar de lunes a lunes los ochos días de
la semana
hundida en depresión
un día despierta y no tenía nada
viviendo ya sola porque eso sí dije ah
quiero ser independiente ya soy todo una
blogger por allá dicen que las personas
que quieren ser empresarias tienen que
salir de su zona de confort un día
llegué a mi ex trabajo donde va a clases
de ballet y le dije la directora
directora ya no voy a hacer maestra
vengo a renunciar porque quiero salir de
mi zona de confort a monos
llegué con mis papás y les dije mamá
papá me voy de la casa porque ya soy
toda una blogger reconocida y quiero ser
independiente mi papá no si no las notas
completa
ya me di cuenta que no que te vaya bien
me voy llegué a una casa que ni siquiera
era mi casa porque la renta va
y un día despierta después de una
borrachera y me di cuenta que no tenía
agua no tenía luz no tiene internet no
tenía dinero imagínense una blogger sin
internet
y de nuevo he apsi victimizándose porque
dios mío porque a mí porque me hiciste
gorda de nuevo porque no me hiciste
guapa como mi mamá porque no soy esa
persona extraordinaria como decía mi
padre pero dije ya si no a ver deja de
victimizar te quieres hacer las cosas
haz las le pedí a la vida le pedí a dios
pero sobre todo a mí y me dije si
quieres esto para ti busque a las
personas correctas y ponte en el camino
correcto a los días conocí al productor
giovanni burgueño quien ahora es mi
manager y socio debo confesar que yo ya
no creía en nadie pero decidí creer en
él y el creer en mí
empecé a hacer las cosas con congruencia
el deber ser y después viene mi quinta
empresa o sexta ya ni sé de tantas veces
que lo intente yap sí quiero
y que creen esta vez sí puse los
cimientos muy firmes me di cuenta que no
podía sola que necesitaba un equipo que
mi egocentrismo no me iba a llevar a
ningún lado que tendría que hacer las
cosas como decían los grandes
empresarios el deber ser y hoy estoy
parado en este escenario
gracias a esas pruebas y error
diciéndoles que la vida y los éxitos no
son de la noche a la mañana lo tienes
que intentar una y otra vez más no
importa el momento por el cual estés
pasando no te juzgues porque siempre lo
que uno hace es decir a mí me está yendo
mal en la vida me juzgo no lo estás
intentando quizás ahorita ya estés en tu
pleno éxito y digas sí pero yo tuve que
pasar por todo esto quizás este es un
día en este momento pero no importa
tienes que intentarlo todos los días
tienes que intentarlo hoy donde el
público me ha dado el título como
influencers quiero decirles que todos
somos influencers todos somos un espejo
yo quiero invitarlos a que sean buenos
influencers buenos hijos buenos
empresarios buenos trabajadores sean los
mejores siempre inténtenlo quien me está
viendo detrás de una pantalla en las
redes sociales quiero decirles que
siempre luchen por sus sueños que no se
queden ahí estancados y hoy entendido
que ser una persona extraordinaria como
me lo decía mi padre es dar siempre el
extra sea lo que sea siempre da el extra
y levántate esta soy yo el resultado de
varios intentos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]